AND GOOD NEWS FOR THE CRITICAL
UPCOMING ELECTION IN
THE COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT, IT
WILL BE ELECTION NIGHT RIGHT
HERE IN AMERICA.
AND THE CRITICAL MIDTERMS, YOU
GOT IT ARE SEVEN DAYS AWAY.
AND WE BEGIN WITH GOOD NEWS
TONIGHT FOR THE GOP, ALONG
WITH AN IMPORTANT WARNING
TO ALL VOTERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT'S COMING.
BUT FIRST, THE GOOD NEWS IN
A SHOCK TO MANY DEMOCRATS,
GENERAL DON BOLDUC HAS NOW
TAKEN A ONE POINT LEAD OVER
THE INCUMBENT, MAGGIE HASSAN IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE SENATE RACE.
THIS WOULD BE A HUGE
REPUBLICAN PICKUP.
NOW, GEN. BOLDUC, BY THE WAY,
TWO PURPLE HEARTS, FIVE BRONZE
STARS, HE AND GOVERNOR SUNUNU
WILL BE ON THIS SHOW TOGETHER
ON THURSDAY NIGHT IN THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON.
REPUBLICAN TIFFANY SMILEY
IS NOW IN A DEAD HEAT.
IT'S AN EVEN RACE WITH PATTY
MURRAY, ACCORDING TO TRAFALGAR.
AND ANOTHER POLL THAT JUST
BROKE MOMENTS AGO.
AND IN MICHIGAN'S GOVERNOR'S
RACE, GET THIS TUTOR, DICKSON.
SHE WILL JOIN US IN A MOMENT.
SHE HAS NOW TAKEN THE LEAD OVER
GRETCHEN WHITMER.
OUT IN ARIZONA, CARRIE LAKE
IS A BIG BLAKE MASTERS IS IN
A STATISTICAL TIE WITH R.
KELLY .
HOWEVER, WE HAVE BIG NEWS FROM
ARIZONA TONIGHT.
IN WHAT IS A HUGE BOOST FOR
BLAKE MASTERS.
THE THIRD PARTY LIBERTARIAN
CANDIDATE JUST DROPPED OUT OF
THE RACE AND HE ENDORSED BLAKE
MASTERS FOR THE SENATE.
POLLS HAD THE LIBERTARIAN
CANDIDATE, MARK VICTOR, POLLING
AT SIX POINTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT'S ANOTHER
SIX A..
MARK KELLY POINTS LIKELY TO GO
TO BLAKE MASTERS OR AT LEAST
A MAJORITY OF THEM.
AND THAT NOW HEAVILY FAVORS
BLAKE MASTERS FOR A PICKUP
WITH REPUBLICANS IN ARIZONA.
MEANWHILE, WE HAVE MORE GOOD
NEWS IN PENNSYLVANIA.
DR. OZ IS FOLLOWING LETTERMAN'S
DISASTROUS DEBATE PERFORMANCE.
BUT IF YOU'RE IN PENNSYLVANIA,
YOU NEED TO BE CAREFUL.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW DUMPING TENS
AND TENS AND TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN ONE SMEAR AD
AFTER ANOTHER ON DR. OZ IN THIS
LAST WEEK OF THE CAMPAIGN,
THEIR DESPERATE TO GET THAT GUY
IN THE HOODIE, THE GUY THAT
NEVER WORKED A DAY IN HIS LIFE,
THE TRUST FUND BRAD THAT ONCE
LEGALIZED HEROIN INJECTION
SITES PAID FOR BY TAXPAYERS.
NO RESTRICTIONS.
ABORTION, A MORATORIUM
ON FRACKING, WANTS TO RELEASE
CONVICTED MURDERERS ANYWAY.
THAT RACE SHOULDN'T BE CLOSE,
BUT IT IS .
SO PAY ATTENTION IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
HERSCHEL WALKER CONTINUES
TO OUTPOLL RADICAL RAPHAEL
WARNOCK IN GEORGIA.
THAT RACE ALSO REMAINS CLOSE
AND PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL NEWS COMES OUT OF
THE DEEP, DEEP BLUE STATE OF
NEW YORK , WHERE REPUBLICAN LEE
ZELDIN IS NOW OFFICIALLY TAKING
THE LEAD IN A BRAND NEW POLL
BY TRAFALGAR.
THAT'S ROBERT HALEYS GROUP.
NOW, LEE ZELDIN WILL BE HERE
AS HE'S CAMPAIGNING
WITH FLORIDA GOVERNOR RHONDA
SANTOS.
THAT'S STRAIGHT AHEAD.
AND NOW THE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
BOTH OF THEM WILL JOIN US NOW.
THE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
ENCOURAGING, BUT LET ME
BE CLEAR AND LET ME PAUSE RIGHT
HERE.
THESE RACES ARE VERY, VERY
CLOSE.
MOST OF THEM ARE WITHIN TWO
POINTS.
SO MAKE NO MISTAKE, IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOUR PREFERRED
CANDIDATE IS IN THE LEAD, IF
YOUR PREFERRED CANDIDATE
IS BEHIND, IF YOUR PREFERRED
CANDIDATE IS IN A DEAD HEAT,
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
DON'T THINK FOR A SECOND THIS
IS A SLAM DUNK.
IN OTHER WORDS, EVERY VOTER
NEEDS TO DO THEIR PART, TAKE
NOTHING FOR GRANTED.
AND DON'T FORGET WHAT IS AT
STAKE.
HERE.
YOU HAVE A RECORD 40 YEAR HIGH
OF INFLATION, WHICH COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE
THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES
AND DIESEL PRICES WE'VE EVER
PAID IN OUR ENTIRE HISTORY.
WE HAVE WIDE OPEN BORDERS,
ALMOST FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS UNDER
JOE BIDEN.
WE HAVE CRIME WAY UP IN SMALL
TOWNS AND BIG CITIES ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE WOKE EDUCATION VERSUS
CLASSICAL EDUCATION WINNING OUT
AND WAY TOO MANY CITIES
AND TOWNS.
AND BY THE WAY, ALL CAUSED
BY THE LIBERAL DEMOCRATS
AND THE RADICAL SOCIALIST
AGENDA.
THEY CONTROL THE HOUSE.
THEY CONTROL THE SENATE.
THEY CONTROL THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY SPEND TRILLIONS ON THIS
NEW ENERGY, THEIR PET PROJECTS.
THEY HAVE STIFLED ALL AMERICAN
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION OF OIL
AND GAS, THE LIFEBLOOD OF
OUR ECONOMY.
THEY WOULD RATHER BIG COUNTRIES
THAT HATE OUR GUTS, LIKE SAUDI
ARABIA, OPEC NATIONS,
VENEZUELA, IRAN AND RUSSIA.
THEN PRODUCE THESE THINGS
DOMESTICALLY.
THEY HAVE RAISED PRICES
DRAMATICALLY AS A RESULT
ON EVERYTHING YOU BUY IN EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO, THEY ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT KEPT YOUR KIDS
OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND YOUR BUSINESS IS SHUT DOWN.
THEY OPENED UP OUR BORDERS LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
THEY RELEASE VIOLENT FELONS
FROM PRISON.
THEY DISMANTLE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND THEY DON'T WANT
BAIL LAWS.
IN MANY OF THESE CITIES
AND STATES.
THEY DO NOT DESERVE YOUR VOTE.
AND I'LL TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER.
THEY DESERVE TO BE FIRED.
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT.
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO FIRE
THEM.
I DON'T.
YOU DO.
COLLECTIVELY, WE DO.
IN FACT, WITH DEMOCRATS IN
CHARGE, SUFFERING WILL ONLY
GET WORSE.
AND NEEDLESS TO SAY, DEMOCRATS
CANNOT RUN ON THEIR RECORD .
AND SAID JOE BIDEN, YOU KNOW,
NOW IN THIS LAST DITCH EFFORT,
WELL, LET'S LIE TO SENIOR
CITIZENS TO SCARE THEM TO DEATH
WITH LIES ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
THEY WANT TAKE AWAY YOUR SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MEDICARE AND CUT
IT.
OKAY, NOT A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN HAS EVER SAID IT.
NO REPUBLICAN SUPPORTS.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND THIS IS DESPERATION
ON DISPLAY.
>> TAKE A LOOK.
THE SENATOR FROM FLORIDA GOING
AFTER MEDICARE AND SOCIAL
SECURITY.
I TELL YOU WHAT I KNOW IS I SAY
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE Y'ALL
BEEN.
>> AND MORE EVERY YEAR, EVERY
SINGLE YEAR, IT SHOULD BE ON
THE CHOPPING BLOCK ALONG
WITH VETERANS BENEFITS
AND EVERYTHING FROM THE BUDGET
.
CONGRESS DOESN'T
VOTE AFFIRMATIVELY.
KEEP IT GOES AWAY, GONE.
YOU'VE BEEN PAYING INTO SOCIAL
SECURITY YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
>> YOU EARNED IT.
NOW, THESE GUYS WANT TO TAKE IT
AWAY.
>> WHO IN THE DO THEY THINK
THEY ARE?
EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE.
WHO IN THE  DO YOU THINK YOU
ARE, JOEY?
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT IS A LIE.
OBAMA HAS BEEN SPREADING
THE LIE.
EVERY DEMOCRAT'S SPREADING LIE
.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN OR CONSERVATIVE THAT
IS ADVOCATING CUTTING VETERANS
BENEFITS, CUTTING SOCIAL
SECURITY OR CUTTING MEDICARE.
SO JOE APPEARS TO BE
MALFUNCTIONING YET AGAIN.
AND I'M SURE, BY THE WAY, MARCO
RUBIO AND RONDA SANTOS ARE
SHAKING THEIR BOOTS BECAUSE
JOE IS DOWN IN FLORIDA BECAUSE
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONLY PLACE
THEY WANT TO SEND HIM BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE NO CHANCE
OF WINNING THERE.
NOW, I THINK THERE'S A ROCKING
CHAIR, BY THE WAY, SOMEWHERE IN
DELAWARE ON THE BEACH WITH JOE
BIDEN'S NAME ON IT.
BUT IF YOU THINK THAT'S BAD,
JUST LISTEN TO HIS LIES ABOUT
INFLATION, TRANSITORY INFLATION
AND IT IS NOW ALMOST OVER.
WE HAVE ZERO INFLATION, NO,
WE'VE HAD NOTHING BUT
NINE STRAIGHT MONTHS OF OF A 40
YEAR RECORD HIGH OF INFLATION.
THANKS TO HIS ENERGY
AND ECONOMIC POLICIES.
>> TAKE A LOOK.
AND THEY TALK ABOUT INFLATION.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE DEALING WITH IT
FOR INFLATION IS A WORLD WIDE
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE WAR IN IRAQ
AND THE IMPACT ON OIL.
AND WHAT'S RUSSIA'S DOING
EXCUSE ME, THE WAR IN UKRAINE
AND THINKING IN IRAQ, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT MY SON THE BECAUSE
OF, YOU KNOW, WOW, THE WAR IN
IRAQ, NONE OF THAT WAS TRUE.
RUSSIA DID NOT CAUSE AMERICA'S
INFLATION CRISIS AND BIDEN'S
SON DID NOT DIE IN IRAQ.
HE HAS SAID IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
IT'S NO WONDER WE WITHIN
A WEEK, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A
PIVOTAL ELECTION.
DEMOCRATS ARE ONCE AGAIN,
THEY ARE TRYING TO HIDE
A LEADER OF THEIR PARTY.
HE IS NOT MENTALLY FIT
TO REPRESENT THE PARTY IN ANY
WAY AS UVA PROFESSOR LEANING
DEMOCRAT LARRY SABATO STATED,
QUOTE, TO THE EXTENT THAT BIDEN
IS LESS VISIBLE AND MAYBE EVEN
INVISIBLE, IT'S A PLUS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
OUT OF SIGHT, OUT OF MIND.
THAT'S WHY JOE IS IN FLORIDA.
DEMOCRATS ELECTION PROSPECTS
THERE ARE PRETTY MUCH NEXT
TO ZERO.
AND IN MARYLAND , WHERE
DEMOCRATS WILL PROBABLY WIN
EVERY MAJOR RACE WITHOUT
A CONTEST.
AND OF COURSE, IN CONTRAST, WE
HAVE FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
IS POUNDING THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
VERY, VERY ANGRY.
OBAMA OUT THERE IN MULTIPLE KEY
STATES THAT ACTUALLY MATTER,
YELLING, SCREAMING AND LYING AT
EVERY SINGLE STOP.
HE WAS IN GEORGIA FOR A RALLY
WITH , OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
HE WAS THERE WITH HIS FELLOW
JEREMIAH WRIGHT LOVER AND LOUIS
FARRAKHAN.
SUPPORTER.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK WAS NOT A BIG
SUPPORTER OF CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, A PROPONENT OF DEFUND
AND DISMANTLE A NO BAIL
MOVEMENT.
WARNOCK ALSO PRAISING FIDEL
CASTRO.
THAT'S THE TRIFECTA.
JEREMIAH WRIGHT, LOUIS
FARRAKHAN AND FIDEL CASTRO.
AND HE DEMANDED, BY THE WAY,
THAT AMERICA REPENT ITS
WHITENESS.
OBAMA THEN TRAVELED
TO MICHIGAN, WHERE HE PRAISED
ON GOVERNOR WHITMAN FOR KEEPING
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL.
FOR YEARS.
AND WITH SOME OF THE WORST
LOCKDOWN RULES IN THE COUNTRY,
AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT ALSO
CAMPAIGN THERE IN WISCONSIN FOR
MANDELA.
BARNS AND BARNS, OF COURSE,
WANTS TO CUT THE PRISON
POPULATION IN HALF.
OH, THAT'S A BRILLIANT MOVE.
HE WANTS TO END CASH BAIL DEEP
IN THE POLICE AND PRAISE
THE TWENTY TWENTY RIOTS.
FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR OF THEM THAT
CONGRESS NEVER INVESTIGATED.
BUT APPARENTLY THAT'S ALL
PERFECTLY FINE WITH BARACK
OBAMA.
HE SUPPORTS ALL OF IT.
NEXT UP IS NEVADA FOR BIDEN'S
RUBBER-STAMP CHRISTINE CORTEZ
MASTO, THEN ON TO ARIZONA FOR
THE COWARDLY KATIE HOBBS,
PERHAPS.
WELL, THE WORST CANDIDATE IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND FINALLY TO PENNSYLVANIA FOR
THE SOCIALIST TRUST FUND BRAD
WHO NEVER WORKED A DAY IN HIS
LIFE IN A HOODIE.
JOHN FETTERMAN, NOW, THIS GUY
IS THE RADICAL OF ALL RADICALS,
LIFELONG OPPONENT OF FRACKING.
HE WANTS A MORATORIUM OBSESSED
WITH LETTING CONVICTED FIRST
DEGREE MURDERERS OUT OF PRISON,
WANTS TO OPEN UP THE PRISON
POPULATION AND THEN RELEASE AT
LEAST A THIRD TO HALF.
HE WANTS PENNSYLVANIA TO BE
A SANCTUARY STATE.
HE WANTS YOU TAXPAYERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE WANTS YOUR MONEY TO FUND
SAFE HEROIN INJECTION SITES.
I'M SURE YOU'RE VERY HAPPY
ABOUT THAT.
AT SOME POINT SOON, OBAMA MIGHT
ALSO WANT TO TAKE A SPECIAL
TRIP TO NEW YORK.
AND BY THE WAY, IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WHEN OBAMA GETS
THERE, DON'T FORGET THAT HE
REFERRED TO AS BITTER AMERICANS
THAT CLING TO YOUR GOD ,
BIBLES, GUNS AND RELIGION.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO COME TO NEW
YORK A